[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Ladies and
gentlemen, artist Mary Little.
[APPLAUSE]
MARY LITTLE: OK, so
most of you know me.
A few of you don't,
and I'm just going
to start with an
introduction about where
I am from and to tell
you a bit about what
I'm going to talk about.
And I'm going to
move my arms around.
It drives me crazy,
and I can't stop it.
I don't have pockets.
So I was born in
Northern Ireland
on a farm, rolling
countryside on a peninsula
that was three miles wide.
And so on the eastern coast,
it was sandy beaches and sand
dunes.
On the west coast, it
was boulders, rocks,
very soft formations, and things
that we could climb on and fall
and not hurt ourselves.
The landscape where
the farms were--
really green, little
rolling hills.
They're called drumlins,
and they're pretty much
the height of two people--
really small.
So you felt really hugged and
enclosed in the environment,
where I grew up.
The farms were-- a
lot of them were--
my uncles and family
were surrounding me.
And ancient fields,
ancient hedges, and it's
like a patchwork-- all
very small and cozy.
So my career took me--
well, from Belfast to
London to Milan and back
to London, California,
and to the Bay Area,
moved to Connecticut, and
then came back to California.
And now I'm in Los Angeles, and
I've been here for three years.
And what I want to
talk about today
is something that is a
really big thing in my life,
and that is that I'm a sculptor,
but I'm also a designer.
So I'm trained as a designer.
I've had seven years'
education as a designer,
but I actually think
and my whole sensibility
is like I work as a designer.
And the way that I like to
design best is if I'm designing
a chair, something that
the body really relates
to-- and generally,
I design for myself--
I like to create objects that
have some kind of relationship
to the body and
respond to the body.
So you deal with
functional things
like making yourself
comfortable,
good seat, good back.
But then it's all
the other things
that make it into
a sculptural thing,
and I want to talk
about that now.
So I'm going to
show some examples,
and it starts with this chair,
which is called the air chair.
Our chair is actually
20 years old.
It was commissioned
by the Museum
of Modern Art in Glasgow,
and they wanted benches
for visitors to sit in.
And it was in the gallery
called the Air Gallery.
It was all white floor,
white walls, and skylights.
So the whole concept and
theme was airiness, lightness.
I wanted to make
chairs that people
could drag around and put
in front of a painting,
so my proposal was 12 chairs.
People could drag
them around, and they
have this kind of like ballet
dancer type feel to the feet,
and everything about them from
the metal structure, the forms
of the plastic to
the plastic feet
is designed to have a sense
of lightness and airiness.
And just for the sake of
this show, it's nice--
or for this talk--
it's nice to put it
in front of some of my
artwork, which I'm doing today.
So you're seeing work
that's 20 years apart,
and you can see that there's
a kind of common sensibility.
And that's the sensibility that
comes from the landscape where
I was raised.
So here, you see two
boulder-like forms,
a bench for two people.
So intimate conversation,
two people sitting together,
head to head, boulder's merge
together, and it's sculptural.
I've shown two photographs
here of this just
to give you some
kind of a sense,
because photographs in 2D
never really put across what
happens in three dimensions.
[INAUDIBLE] of this.
This is called [? Gliss, ?] and
it's the same kind of concept,
where it's two boulder-like
forms merged together,
but they're merged differently.
And the thing I want to
bring your attention to here
is the little blue eyes
that are popping through.
So I love working with cloth,
and the whole nature of my life
has just been really doing
different things with cloth.
This is very rare.
I have very small amounts of it.
It's called shibori.
It's made by master
craftsmen in Japan.
And I wanted to
do something where
I was using this really
sparingly, but really
powerfully.
So I've put these
little pieces--
I've slit the felted wool seat
and have these little raised
areas that are coming through.
That's the second view of it.
I'll just go back one
more time to give you
a three-dimensional view.
And there's a real
ugliness to this piece,
and there's a lot of my work,
where there's an ugliness
and beauty at the same time.
And I really enjoy that.
I enjoy it when there's a kind
of a challenge to the work,
and that's not necessarily in
everything, but it is in some.
So this chair that I designed--
it was finished in 1985,
and it's bringing together
everything that I think
is important in
design, as I see it.
So that is I want to
see if it enhances how
you feel when you sit in it.
I want a chair that enhances
how you look when you sit in it
and one that looks amazing
as a sculptural object when
no one's sitting in it at all.
And so when you're
sitting on this chair,
you sit on the
wooden seat, and you
can see there's nothing
to impede your movement.
You can move your legs around
in lots of directions--
a bit more than 180 degrees.
Lean against the black, which
is actually stretched rubber,
if you lean against that.
This is me, 1985.
My hairdresser's here.
He can see how little
my hair has changed.
And it's gone gray.
And so if you think
about it, I always
want people to sit
really properly,
because it's good for your back.
But who does?
We all sit asymmetrically.
We all move over to one side
or another, and at that time,
I knew that I sat
way over to one side.
I was always leaning
over to the right.
I was always having my
right leg over my left.
And so I developed
this chair that
really allowed me to do that,
so when I sit in the chair,
I feel amazing.
The black leather, or the
black rubber, is stretched,
so it gives me a
real firm support.
And because of the form,
it lets me move around.
So I'm kind of feeling majestic
when I'm sitting in this chair.
I feel good.
I know that I can look good.
After that, I really got into
cloth, working with fabric.
And I have really
done that all my life,
but this is when I really
professionally, seriously
got into working with
fabric with my art.
So the chair on
the left I call it
Rudolf, kind of after the
ballet dancer, of course,
because it looks like
it's poised and dancing.
But it's a descendant
of the blue chair,
so there's a lot of
the same ideas, where
when you're sitting
in this chair,
you've got your arms out,
and you feel very expansive.
This chair is actually exploring
having your arms out further
than in the blue chair.
But the thing I want
to talk about with this
is just it's the
combination of two things.
So the form making is with
carving foam and putting fabric
on tight around it.
And then there's also in
the legs and the lower part,
there's making
forms and character
with the fabric
as a loose cloth.
There's nothing
inside but layers of--
interfacing the
stiffness, a stiff sheet,
and it's really to do with
the way the cloth is cut.
The chair on the right, Liz,
is a similar thing, but more
voluptuous forms in the bottom.
It's only full of air.
It's actually not
only full of air,
because it's got the tubular
steel frame that supports you.
And so it's that they all
have tubular steel legs
and structure, and then
the only other thing
that's inside the legs is air.
So it's a pattern-making
and the layers of stiffeners
that are inside, but
the thing I wanted
to talk about here
with Liz on the right
is it's got a regular seat.
It looks pretty comfortable.
It's got a regular back.
And then it's got this orb
on the right hand side,
and remember, I
talked about me having
a sense of always wanting to
be over on the right hand side.
So I put the arm on
the right hand side.
Underneath this silk fabric,
that's actually just a sphere.
It's an orb, a
very firm support.
When you look at it, you think,
what's that thing doing there?
It's going to get in the
way when you sit on it.
But when you sit
down on it, it's
just absolutely the
perfect place for your arm
or for your elbow.
So you just sit down,
put your arm down,
and you're totally casual.
You just-- like
at the minute, I'm
here up in front of all of
you, and I feel a bit awkward.
But when you're
sitting in the chair,
and if the armrests are
in just the right place,
it just really makes you feel
wonderful and relaxed and good
about yourself.
And that's how you should
be in a piece of furniture.
Aesthetically, stylistically,
I, at the time,
was looking at things like
Hans Holbein paintings,
and there were an abundance
of in the National
Gallery in London.
And so there, there
was a lot to do
with how silk was represented
and how cloth was represented
and the strange hats
from the 17th century.
It was all such an inspiration.
I have masses of
imagery from that time
that we're really-- they just
make my heart go when I think
about them or look at them.
And this is Margaret, and
it's from the same series.
And here, I'm cutting away foam.
So if you think about
it, very often, you're
sitting in the chair, and
you're really relaxed.
You have no requirement
whatsoever for support
in between your legs, so
I started carving away,
cutting away the foam
in between my legs.
I've made sure that I've got
a nice length under my knees,
so I've got good
support under my legs
when I'm sitting really relaxed.
And then I've got really
good lumbar support in this.
Nobody ever thinks my chairs are
comfortable, and I love that.
But when you sit on them,
you just feel a sense of wow.
And I actually hear
that word, wow,
when people sit in my chairs.
And it tells me they were
thinking that something
horrible would happen
to them, and it doesn't.
And so this has
lumbar support in it,
but it's got this
slit up the back.
And if you think
about it, your spine--
your spine doesn't need support.
It's the flesh on either
side that needs support.
So I cut it away, and
those are all the kind
of thinking where it lets
me do sculptural forms when
I take a lead from the body.
So the fabric in
this, the fabric
is-- this is the first time
where I really kind of felt
like I was getting
a hold of what
I was doing with the fabric.
If you look at the back, and
it looks like it's opening up,
it's like old fashioned
jodhpur pants.
And so the full form,
and then there's
inner formers that
I've put inside.
So I'm building up a whole
battery of tools and materials
that let me make forms that
are full forms in fabric,
but there's a kind of
flexibility to them.
I'm able to achieve
the forms that I want,
but there's a control there.
It's not just fabric.
Little inch-high
stools-- these are petal
shapes, definitely referencing
the kind of sensibility
that I developed with growing up
in the countryside in Northern
Ireland and always that
kind of gentle softness.
But here, I've looked
at Dior clothing.
And if you think about
collars on dresses
and them standing up, so I
wanted to replicate and explore
that kind of concept.
The fabric is a synthetic silk.
It has a robustness,
and it's iridescent,
which is really nice,
because it really pulls out
the quality of the
three-dimensional form
and the folds and
the stretching.
And when someone has
one of these pieces,
then they can arrange the
collar just as they want.
A client in New York wanted
to have a chair for herself,
and it was a daytime chair.
She wanted it to
be white, and she
wanted to sit on it every day.
So immediately, my
brain thinks practical--
how do you make a
white chair that's
really good for multiple years
and looks good all the time?
And this is a woman
that came to me,
because she was a collector.
She collected the fiber
arts, glass arts, ceramics,
and collected furniture.
So she was commissioning
this piece,
and I was listening to how
she wanted to use the chair.
She wanted to read
the newspaper.
She wanted to be on the phone.
She wanted to do needlepoint,
so she wanted to sit astride.
So it became a
chaise longue that's
narrower enough for her to
sit on with her legs astride.
And I proposed quilting, and
quilting is a really good way
to have a white base cotton,
make it very hard-wearing,
but to bring in really
interesting textures
and patterns so that
in the background,
it's referencing waterfalls.
And the seat part is
referencing tiles,
which are both things
that I was thinking
of for hot climate, because
she actually wanted this
for her home in Palm Beach.
And this client in--
she had an art
gallery in Chelsea,
and she wanted a
desk and a couple
of tables for her brochures
and so on, her catalogues.
And I wanted to do
something really tied
back and minimal for
her, but something
that expressed her gentle and
kind of feminine personality.
Working with white wool--
and I've made
reference to things
like leather, leather
chaps, leather stirrups,
if you think of horse riding.
I'm also making a reference
in the quilting on the table
on the left to Chanel handbags.
So I wanted to have multiple
layers in that part, where
the quilting is.
I've got multiple layers
to give it that full form.
I quilted them together,
and the quilting--
I knew I had to quilt it.
I knew I had to stitch it,
so what are the images?
What's the icon that
you want to pick up on?
And it was the Chanel handbag.
So in my case, in this one,
it's sketched really loose.
I basically just drew it
with the sewing machine.
I didn't mark it.
I made rough crisscross
marks to keep it very casual.
And then at other
times, I do things
that are very flamboyant.
So I know I work at
either end, so there's
this great flamboyance
in the stool here.
And it's felted
wool, and it's a mix
of a yellow, intense
yellow, with black.
I was looking at things
like flamenco dresses,
and there's something about
me I just-- there are times
with working in the
furniture world,
I very often was working
with a lot of guys.
And it's really great
to do something that's
a lot more feminine
and flamboyant
and put it there right
in front of them.
So I love that.
And this chair, this
was a commission
for a woman in Washington, DC.
And it's called Fleur.
I call my furniture
sometimes after the clients.
Not all the time,
but this time I did.
So looking back, this was a
real turning point for me.
This is just three years old.
I did this when I first
moved to Los Angeles.
And with her, I had done three
sketches for design proposals
for her, and she chose one.
I looked it up, and I
thought, wow, I've just done--
I've got this really soft
pencil, really thick layer,
and I'd just done
squiggle for the leg.
And now I had to
interpret it, so how
do you interpret a soft
pencil squiggle on a leg
into something that's in fabric
and really rich and really
is of a quality that
needs to be in--
she was putting together a
private gallery or museum
in DC.
And so I started to
do lots of trials.
I do many, many
trials in muslin.
I'm always-- I start
with one single sketch,
and then everything
else from there is 3D.
I'm a 3D spatial kind of person.
I can't really think flat.
So with lots of trials,
came up with this thing,
where the fabric is
cut in a curvy line,
and then sewn together.
And sewn together, it gives it
this three-dimensional form.
And it's much, much
more complex than that,
but that's enough to go with.
But the fabric here was
a really high-quality mix
of wool and silk, and
because of those two
together, the wool gave it this
beautiful softness and drape,
and the silk gave it the sheen.
So it really picks up the
suppleness, the wavy lines.
It's like a really shiny
woman with really shiny hair.
And so that, for me,
felt really important,
and that was something
that I wanted
to go back to again and again.
I made many trials, many
different kinds of objects
from this kind of motif.
And this is something
where it really
transformed into
something else, so
in my home, a loft in downtown,
I needed to divide space,
so I made a cloth wall.
This is artist canvas, so
it's unbleached artist canvas.
And it's put together with
just repeated patterns,
and when it's sewn
together, it makes
these three-dimensional reliefs.
And it picks up--
I have an east-facing
window, so it picks up
the lights, the relief, the
shadow, repeated pattern.
Because it's fabric,
and it doesn't
have a lot of structure, it
has that kind of looseness
as well and kind of untidiness.
And I love the way it just hits
the floor, in a rough manner,
hitting the floor.
So I started to think of--
sorry, whoops.
Just want to go back one more.
So I wanted to get into
staining this white cloth.
I bought a roll of canvas,
staining the white,
working with shadow,
working with pattern,
working with repeat
pattern, and seeing
what I could do if I completely
ignored function and completely
ignored anything that
had to do with having
a relationship with the body.
And that was kind
of a little scary,
but it was also a
real liberation.
I felt really
excited to do this.
So I have periods of time, where
I'm just working for two weeks
and not going out, where I
just have a mass of ideas,
and I'm making
them, exploring here
pattern, life,
light, and relief.
And with this one, this
is about 84 inches long.
Looking at how the
pattern can be mid dense,
so there's three blocks
of very dense pattern,
and you get much
more intense shadow.
And with ever such
a slight change--
and this is the kind of
thing I am interested in now,
how you can get a really
big change in outcome
with the smallest of iterations,
the smallest of changes.
With this one, which
I've called Dunbar,
the pattern that you saw
previously, I call it a motif.
Here, I put it horizontal.
I've made the center
section a little wider,
and the upper and the
bottom sections are lower.
And it really brings
out the fleshiness.
Working with gravity,
it really brings out
the fleshiness of the fabric.
And there's two
stories to this that I
think are really important.
And one of them is I had a
visitor come to see this.
She was a girlfriend of a
friend, and at one point,
I saw her in front of this
piece, and she was crying.
And I said, what's up?
How can you be crying
in front of this work?
And she said, it just
touches me so much.
It just moves me so much.
And I don't really
know what it is,
but I just can't stop crying.
So I thought, that's the most
amazing accolade for someone
to do that.
And the other was a
really good friend
of mine, who came to see it,
and she's had three children.
And when she looked at this,
she said, I can't look at this.
This is-- I don't know if
she said the word gross,
but she hinted it
emotionally, and she said,
this reminds me of how I am
today rather than how I really
want to be.
And I've had that comment
from another person years
ago when I did a chair for her.
She saw a chair
that I had designed,
and she wanted
something similar.
When I made it, she hated it.
And I said, what's wrong?
And she said, Mary, I'm so
sorry, but the one that I saw
was of me when I
was an 18-year-old,
and the one that you've
got in front of me
here is me as I am today,
and I'm 45 years old,
and I've had two children.
And I told her, take it home.
Don't pay for it, and I'll
call you in three weeks' time,
knowing absolutely
with 100% certainty
that she'd love it
in three weeks' time.
And she did.
She loved it.
She paid me, and now she's
a really great friend,
and she's commissioned maybe
eight pieces over the years.
So that's just a fantastic
thing when your work has
that kind of impact on people.
And then in contrast,
something like this
is just real joy, very happy,
flamboyant spontaneity.
And that's great too.
And so they're in
the gallery here,
and there's a large piece
that's 10 foot by 10,
and it's picking up on the
thing that's on this piece here.
This is called
O'Reilly, and it's just
like referencing seaweed,
referencing an awful lot
of the things from my
background, which is always
what I'm going back to.
And then this
piece has got the--
I wanted to do something that
was just a simple rectangle,
but it had a burst
of fabric coming.
And this is very
much to do with how
I like to make three-dimensional
forms out of this cloth
that I'm now becoming
so familiar with.
So I made this piece, hung
it up, and took it off,
hung it up back
to front, thought
it was so much more
interesting back to front,
because here you can see the
lines that are coming in.
You can see what's
called seam allowances.
So when the two pieces of
fabric are sewn together,
there's half an inch
strip on either side.
And then when that opens it up,
when that opens up in the way
that I do it, you've
got much more texture.
And it gives this surface--
it's a large white
surface, but it
gives that kind of
texture and relief
and picks up on the shadow.
And then I was going to
cut all the rest into--
I started to cut the sides
into a long slim rectangle,
but just loved the
outer edges, loved
the kind of
serendipity of finding
something that
was really playing
with the circle in the middle.
And it took me about two weeks
of coming back and forward
to this and just getting other
people to comment on it to make
me realize that this is
just how it should be,
and I need to stop
right where I am.
And that's one of the really
exciting things, just if I--
well, the thing that excites me
about what I do, I have a plan.
And then I work really
very much in 3D.
I'm working like a
sculptor, and then there's
so many really interesting
things that come out of that
that I can go with or not.
So there's a huge
sense of judgment
and a bit of courage
that needs to be taken.
So these are four
panels, 24 by 24,
and this is the first
time I've stretched
the canvas onto wooden
stretchers, wooden frame.
And I really enjoyed it.
You've got the
large white tautness
around this looseness
in the middle.
Each of these is made
in a different way.
They're each made from two
pieces of cloth sewn together,
but the inner line, inner seam
is hand-drawn, and some of them
are flat.
Some of them have got
second little dimples.
And then when I put
them up on the wall,
I just manipulate them
and play with them
and see what I want to
come to bring out of it.
This is a similar concept.
It's much more
controlled, regulated.
Each piece is
absolutely identical,
and in doing this,
of course, there's
the reference to the artist
Lucio Fontana, where he slashes
his stretched canvasses.
In my case, I've
seen them together,
and then the seam line runs
inside where you can't see it.
But you've got this really
lovely sensual forms that are
happening all over it, really.
And it picks up the shade,
the shadow, the highlights,
and just really beautiful
way that the cloth folds in.
And this is me working
to the absolute minimal
that I probably
would do, where it's
the same principle as previous.
This piece is actually in
the exhibition here as well.
And it's just a little
dimple, and the little dimple,
before it goes in, it comes out.
And it's actually--
I see it sensual, but it is
a very sexual piece as well,
framed in a kind of
modernist squareness.
And then this motif
you've seen before.
But what was exciting
about this was
that I put it onto
the stretch panel,
and it looked so different.
So the previous ones were
just hung from the top,
and the canvas let to
fall however it wanted.
And this is pulled really tight,
and it's the margin around it
that is around it
that I find something
that I like to control.
I like to think about the
boundary of the pieces.
And here, you've got
practically no boundary at all.
The pattern moves out
as far as possible.
You've got the little dimples.
Now they're horizontal
and repeated.
I've made as many as I
can within the framework.
And people are making
references to metal fences.
And really when people look at
my work or really any artwork,
they're going to look
at it and say, oh,
that reminds me of XYZ.
And it's all to do with what
your own personal history is
and what your own
experiences are.
And that's something that, as an
artist, you have to let go of.
You make a piece, and
then you put it out,
and people are going to see
it how they personally want
to see it, or it just happens.
But so if you look at
this, the pattern of this,
and then immediately after, this
is exactly the same pattern.
So I make patterns in paper.
This is exactly the same
paper pattern as previous,
except this one is
stretched really tight.
So the dimple is
pulled really taut.
It's got very
controlled aesthetic,
and then this one hangs up,
and it does its own thing.
And I love that.
When I hung this up, the
first thing I thought
was-- well, actually
before it was hung up,
I thought, I'll
hang it up, and then
I'm going to make it
really neat and tidy.
I'll just start at the
top, neaten it all up,
and work all my way down
and make it really neat.
But as soon as I turned
around and stood back from it,
turned around and
looked at it, I thought,
I love this just as it is.
And so every time I take
it down and put it back up,
it's different, because
it's a malleable.
It's soft, flexible cloth.
I just love the randomness of
this kind of thing and the way
it picks up light
in different ways
and the way that the edge is
not crisp, regular corners,
and then the sides here--
it goes in and out.
It does its own thing.
In this piece, which
I called [? Man, ?] is
exactly the same as
this, but the pattern
is four times the size.
So this is one of
the other things
that I'm exploring is scale and
how that affects the canvas--
from the narrow palette
that I'm working within,
how much you can do within it.
And then this is
another one where
the pattern goes vertically
rather than horizontal,
and it's really dense.
And then there's the
margin up at the top,
just one margin at the top.
That's depth.
And then on the
sides, just because
of the length that I've
let it stay, it comes out.
So when you walk around this
piece, you can see behind.
You can see the sides.
And then at the
bottom, the margin
is so tight to the pattern
that it just hugs the wall.
And I love that kind of thing.
This is an aran sweater, a
traditional Irish sweater.
And when I-- well,
this time last year,
I was in Belfast
with all thy family,
and my mom died
this time last year.
And we were clearing her house,
and I find this little bag,
a little gift bag, and inside
with this tiny little baby
sweater.
It really is literally
a really little thing.
And I knew why it was there.
It was because each one
of us, when we wanted to--
if we had a friend who was
having a baby, we'd call my mom
and say, can you make
her a little sweater?
Can you make him
a little sweater?
And sometimes she
had some in stock,
so this one I took
and photographed this,
put it on Instagram, and I
was just sitting and looking
at Instagram, looking at
that photograph one night,
and all around me in the
studio, I could see my work.
And I thought, wow, this
is so close to my work.
And I have not seen
it before, and this
was maybe a year and a half into
me making my bleached canvas
pieces, working with relief.
And I truly had not
seen the connection.
And so she worked with yarn,
unbleached, knit it together
into traditional patterns that
always had a massive infinite
variations.
I was doing just the same.
So the first time
I had the chance--
I make all of my
works in series.
First time I had a
chance, I decided
to make a series of pieces
that were inspired by my mom
and inspired by aran sweaters.
So the key thing
is scale, and using
a couple of different
motifs and patterns
and putting them together.
And in this one,
it's called Sheila.
And all of the pieces
are roughly 60 by 60.
So the pattern from an
earlier piece, another pattern
going horizontally
from a different piece,
so I'm looking at--
I'm really revisiting
the patterns
that I've developed,
which is really,
for me, an exciting
thing to do, because I
get to know them better.
Betty, this is called.
That was my mom's name.
Nice kind of cleanness along
the bottom, really intense
busyness.
Not sure what I think of this
sometimes when I look at it.
I love the little dimples
that are in the lower parts,
so I'm trying to put pattern
within pattern and pattern
against pattern.
And then in this one, I
really love the white expanse
at the top, and
the white expanse
is a contrast to the very
much flamboyance, folds
of fabric in the bottom.
And so at the top,
it's all stripes.
They're maybe 2 and 1/4,
2 and 1/2 inches wide,
and you get that kind
of dimply natural effect
that comes from it.
And just the
contrast of the two--
for me, this is one of
my most successful pieces
of the later works.
But I know that everybody,
when they look at work,
they see something different.
This is the last piece
that I'm going to show you,
and this is where the title
of this exhibition comes from
and the title of
this talk, and that's
"Intent and Serendipity."
And I think you
probably know already
that all the way through
there's intent, which
is in design, planning,
forward thinking,
but then there's what happens
when something happens that you
didn't quite expect, or how
do you relate to this thing
when you're thinking
like a sculptor
and feeling like a sculptor?
How do you relate to this
thing when, actually, it
turns out to be something
that isn't what you expected?
So I hung up this piece.
One of the really funny things
is when I hang up a piece,
and I'm right up
close, walk away--
I have to walk away nine feet--
and then standing there
with my back to it thinking,
what am I going to see?
Because so many
times, I just don't
know what I'm going to see.
It's just so different when
it's on the wall from when
I'm making it.
So I hung this piece up,
turned around and looked at it,
and I could see all those
little mask-type pieces.
They weren't like that.
But one of them was, and I
started to play around with it,
punch it, and push it
through, push it back, just
make it into something
that I hadn't intended.
It's got such a much more
three-dimensional sense to it.
And there's one, two, three
different patterns within that.
And then when you think
of it wider, there's more.
So this just sums
up what I was trying
to do with my mom's aran
patterns and the inspiration
from that.
And so all my life, I have been
a furniture designer, sculptor,
and just in the last
three years since making
that large canvas
that was for my room,
I have been working on something
that is devoid of anything
to do with function
in relation--
anything that has a
relationship to my body.
And I keep thinking,
will I miss this?
But it's actually the opposite.
I have very few narrow
options in what I'm exploring.
And I find that the
constraints of those options
are making me even
more creative.
I thought I'll maybe dry up.
It will be something that
I'll do for six months.
But really, it just feels
like I can't wait to go home
to keep on making more.
That's how it feels.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]